[Music]
Comcast 47 seconds of logos no lie James
Cameron saw in the first three minutes
of this film and had to excuse himself
to change out of his premature
ejaculation jeans why is this asshole
even startled here they left the island
completely unattended right doesn't it
stand to reason that it would be fucking
overrun with Dinosaurs by now why are
they backing out of the site instead of
turning the fuck around
are you out marine one um marine one is
the name of the helicopter that flies
the President to and fro not whatever
underwater craft you're talking about
here what is that well considering your
squarely in the park that at last check
contained a t-rex I'm gonna guess this
is the smoke monster from lost this
movie should have been called scream -
scream harder given the fact that we
don't even know these assholes aren't we
honestly rooting for the t-rex here
[Music]
premature celebration wait the
Mosasaurus bit off the ladder and the
guy but it had no impact on the
helicopter itself and not only that but
after seeing this happen these mothers
stand around staring instead of getting
the hell out of there
damn haven't seen CGI fire this
impressive since 1997 spawn three years
after the fall of Jurassic world news
position jus narration the islands long
dormant volcano has shown considerable
unrest in recent months if there's a
news organization monitoring this island
so closely why didn't anyone notice the
main gate is wide open the US Senate has
convened a special committee does the US
Senate have any jurisdiction here though
Isla Nublar is right next to Costa Rica
and I don't think it has any American
tax regardless shouldn't this be a
pretty international decision do
dinosaurs deserve for the same
protections given to other endangered
species No
or should they be left to die true story
the dinosaur protection group was the
original name of the band Dinosaur Jr
after that they shortened it to DPG then
went back to the full name for two years
with a new drummer then changed the name
to Jefferson dinosaur then dinosaurs
starship then ultimately and finally
dinosaur jr. dinosaurs are living and
breathing but soon they're gonna have to
watch them go extinct or not I am legit
offended this movie is trying to make
the let the dinos live side something I
feel empathy for dinosaurs they went
extinct for a reason fools people like
you make a difference great this works
also after receiving support from the
congresswoman Claire immediately
terminates this call we cannot condone
government involvement on what amounts
to a privately owned venture also
dinosaurs would kill all the humans very
quickly but I realized logic is not
involved in these proceedings like most
congressional proceedings have noticed
I'm gonna die yet no one cares roll
credits please so if we could access
that system our ability to locate and
capture those animals safely would
increase tenfold discount cerebro movie
hero is living off the grid at an RV
while building something cliche while
all these damned Jurassic movies have to
open with someone being talked into
going to a dinosaur island or back don't
is it because they only have the one
story to tell and they just keep finding
slight new variations for it how is it
you
they also can't have a jurassic world
film without these two bickering over
their previous off-screen relationship
what I should just build my own cab and
play pool and drink beer all day why
does she make the American dream sound
like a bad thing you're just gonna let
her die
well yeah movie should be over right
here dunzo finito logic wins u.s.a u.s.a
come on you're better man don't you
think you are you should write fortune
cookies okay but this isn't really a
fortune shouldn't the joke be greeting
cards is it too much to ask the writers
to be less than narcoleptic when they
type this dialogue relax more likely die
riding on a horse than in a plane oh
yeah so that's a language not approved
language not a bro language Barbara you
know your mother's we could sense of
humor skip movie thinks we're still jaw
dropped in awe at these same and cliffs
and waterfalls for the fifth goddamn
time and we are not from the run time by
dialing down the majesty of a place I've
been to several times and wasn't really
asking to go back to from being honest
okay look it's possible the remaining
dinosaurs did some damage to the
facilities after the island was
abandoned but the movies making
everything look like it's been ages
since anyone was here and it's only been
three years
he's flying Dino assholes remind me that
there are dinos that can fly and at
least some of them would have bounced
from danger island as soon as the
volcano started runway sure Costa Rica's
about 120 miles away but there are
plenty of alien creatures that can make
that trip without breaking a sweat it's
true I googled it and everything this is
clearly some kind of homage I suppose
but in this context it doesn't make any
sense the first movie had something
large in the mirror creating the visual
part of the gang here it's just oh it
I'd remove five hundred sins if blue ate
him right here
Oh Lord he's gonna drink wouldn't Lee
himself out of this isn't he I think
they were going for tension here but
watching him flop around on the ground
is more like reliving Lego Batman's
tantrum also dude even if the lavas not
touching him it's hot enough Owen is
literally toast right now this guy has
instantly gained access to any system
he's tried but he can't override the
doors deep breaths
or you could get back on the computer
and keep trying to open those doors no
please mother
seriously didn't see this ladder this
entire time yep they're about to survive
all this of all the routes out of the
jungle owen takes the exact path that
leads to the facility and syncs it up
perfectly when they try to escape what
are the odds seriously what are the
fucking odds also owen is able to outrun
all these dinosaurs who are running it
pretty much the same rate of speed
despite their size differences and who
are also taking the exact same route is
Owen I don't want to on effects
departments too much because they're
typically overworked and underpaid but
seriously man seriously why are they
pausing right now just because they
found a giant keep tree trunk I thought
the whole point of the last few minutes
was to run this dinosaur takes a break
from escaping the exploding island to be
a threatening dick to the humans instead
of just outright eating them king t-rex
machina again like do something new you
dicks this has the dramatic tension of a
door of the explorer episode with less
believability he's too long next back
here look like they're circular miles
are open and I choose to believe that
they sound like mr. bill Wow in the
middle of all this ocean and all these
dinosaurs Owen is able to track these
folks down and I'm just about done
giving any it's about this movie the
shape of waterfall in Kingdom huh sure
was nice of the erupting volcano and the
escaping dinosaurs to take a break and
let these guys catch at the breath god
is this movie trying to be lost world
all over again
is it like star trek into darkness where
you're literally making the same movie
but you change just enough to keep a
straight face when promoting the film as
not the same movie they could have saved
a few bucks and literally use footage
from 2012 here and no one would know the
difference weird this is exactly like
speed and that there is nothing ramp
like at the end of that pier to create
lift for the vehicle yet the vehicle
lifts only with speed it was 25 years
ago and in 2018 you have to do better
than this crap a movie about a military
outfit stealing rescuing genetically
created dinosaurs from a violent island
volcano eruption might be the weirdest
place for a John Deere product placement
ever certainly weirder than that one in
Caligula also yep that John Deere kept
is all the disguise you need John Deere
perfect for lawn care heavy machinery
and subterfuge you know the back half of
the island doesn't look half bad and is
probably pretty safe from the lava
couldn't they have moved all the over
there all this is in the past I want to
talk to you about the future I'll give
you ten minutes
yeah but how is this not discussed
before dr. Zola showed up to buy the
dinosaurs today
how does he I even keep Lockwood in
business and here's the part where
discounts Sam Rockwell
not truman capote that there are plans
for yet another launch of yet another
secret park lab diner with a and I think
at this point we could all have a heart
attack and die if not surprised
and thanks to own Grady's research it
follows human in command go off and blue
barely ever followed Owens command his
research scientifically speaking is a
speck of dust from which you could
definitely not genetically alter fuckin
lab-grown dinosaurs to obey human
goddamn commands you can swilling
huckster on the movie The Blues been
bleeding this month since she got shot
she'd be as dead as disco by now her
blood type should be close enough but
for a car divorce with two or three
fingers no more than three I think
there's one more ting dude just said in
the previous scene that they got eleven
species off the island but sure one of
those eleven will have a blood type
close enough to match blue shirt not
even close to the biggest ass this movie
has made so far also how the patina
wasn't she captured and being held under
armed guard did they cover next to the
ships manifest officer or something and
then they go to apparently one container
and find the one dinosaur she was
referring to and who she did not mention
was a t-rex do I have this right also
the how notwithstanding wind at the
Mercs captured the t-rex it was clearly
on the run with Owen and the crew a few
minutes ago
and there's no way they could get it
before they left it is movie saying
there's more than one now cuz I'm pretty
sure there's always been just the one
open I got no reason to wonder or check
why it's open I'm just a voice outside a
cargo container do I care about it I
don't even know what my name is dog
some boat entrance to the super secret
underground laboratory is intensely
guarded by a four digit keypad entry but
beyond that this place is unsecure
I've stayed in Holiday Inns with more
security than this place Jesus Christ
not only have they accused the use of
pink screen savers on the computers
they've got the expositional blu video
perfectly cued up and someone took the
time to edit all his video diaries
together in a narrative that would make
sense to someone as young as a little
girl god they could have called this
movie Jurassic world a series of
unfortunate coincidences this movie
proves my theory once and for all that
unattended children are literally the
worst Dino transfusion is illusion to
cause confusion
despite its inclusion suggesting a
foregone conclusion they were able to
quickly steal some t-rex blood but not
anymore Fein crocodile tears of what I'm
doing here Biddy whoa he definitely saw
her twice in four seconds time but
because it's a movie I guess he didn't
or something keep her in there and keep
the door locked um shouldn't be too hard
since you locked it with what I assume
is the only key and I also assume this
is unlike any door in the universe that
can be unlocked from the inside they all
seriously nodded off in a crowded cell
with an injured Velociraptor I mean I
guess they trust her and she's
restrained but how do you fall asleep
right next to a goddamn Velociraptor
even though this was the most important
asset on this bizarro Noah's Ark and was
close to death Wheatley didn't check up
on her all night every scene in this
movie appears to be trying to out lucky
the previous scenes and it's not fun as
a viewer it's like a bunch of
firstworldproblems got together with
situational privilege and a few humble
brags and they all wrote a screenplay
then they shove that your face on
Instagram when they sold it for millions
we what the hell time is it when they
pulled into the dock it looked like dawn
now it's pretty much pitch-black again
and Maisie got in trouble at the same
time that they were digging the bullet
out of blue which was definitely at
night when Eli shut her in the room in
California it was broad daylight so
unless the Sun moves in the opposite
direction and the Jurassic universe this
is some dynamite state okay even more
Dino Lockwood's estate is in northern
California the crew left Isla Nublar
which is off the coast of Costa Rica
around dusk and a big-ass cargo ship and
it's only been a few hours since they
left movie what the
really think you could get away with it
in my own house he did because he did
you exploited a living thing in a cage
for money you exploded an awesome
franchise for money so bye Felisha
you never thought about the applications
of your research Olin how many millions
a trained predator might be worth
villain expose it's his evil plan to the
protagonist instead of outright killing
them cliche this is such a cliche that I
think there's even a Geico commercial
that makes fun of it as far as everybody
else is concerned today burned up on the
island yeah but Eli doesn't know if they
contacted anyone else since they've been
back right speaking of which why didn't
they contact someone else as soon as
they got back the arrival of the
International dinosaur buyers and the
limos with the secrecy and the auction
whatnot this movie's third act is a
blatant ripoff of take him this little
girl here climbs the walls like she's a
goddamn Jason Bourne and I'm in awe of
her but also not buying it for one
second and also I think a normal kid
would take their chances trying to sneak
past the guard in the hallway before
trying the spider-man I understand her
value but I raised
I raised both of them goddamn it it is
not possible even in a stupid movie that
this girl is this good at hiding within
earshot of perfect exposition every
fucking time
here's another movie that suggests if
you want to sell a super high dollar
item to a super small segment of the
super rich population of Earth it's easy
to get them all together in the same
room in a few weeks notice and anyone
that ever planned any kind of basic
homecoming or class reunion of any sort
can tell you that's a lot welcome to
this extraordinary evening what it's
still evening did we literally skip an
entire day here and I thought Dobby the
house-elf was expecting the dinosaurs
yesterday so why didn't his buyer show
up then - was there even an attempt to
map out the time line in this movie you
know if you're gonna have a live auction
you should probably turn the lights on
right what if in the back tries to lay
down 12 million for the Triceratops and
the auctioneer cannot see all the
attendees that might be bidding ten
million dollars sold honestly 10 million
for a dinosaur is the biggest joke in
this movie these things should be going
for a couple hundred million at the low
end they are fucking living dinosaurs a
condo in Manhattan cost 10 million the
dumbwaiter goes straight from Lockwood's
room to the fucking dinosaur facility
how did he not hear any of this being
built or at least the endo Raptor roars
amazing oh god she's gonna adopt this
little girl like she's Travolta in
face-off isn't she the end
not gonna lie the Indo Raptor looks like
a little bit of a bitch 20 million this
is a prototype not for sale then why
didn't Claudia stipple Smith make that
clear in the first place he said it was
a preview but he didn't say the endo
wrapper wasn't for sale that thing can
leave this building
what about the t-rex though come on Owen
is a Navy vet but he's nothing Wolverine
Buffalo Bill here wins the stupid prize
by opening this cage door and in this
movie there were a lot of contenders for
that prize man the end of this movie
makes the five-story house with a
network of underground tunnels and a
three-story tall underground auction
room seem super looking small what do
you think twelve Hammond is awkward
apart Lockwood never had a grandchild so
clone KITT I mean yeah the dinos have
always been clones in these movies so
it's not that big of a leap from a fake
movie science standpoint but from a
storytelling perspective it's not very
original he made her a Hannah
here's another Jurassic movie that wants
to act like large killer dinos can get
this screen closed without making a
sound which they cannot you I need blood
samples from the Raptor how in the
ever-loving did Franklin get here from
the dock this is a dumb movie dumber
than rampage dumb dumber than emoji
movie dumb dumber than Dumb and Dumber
to dumb
Blu MacLean narrowly avoids death by
jumping away from a bad CGI explosion at
the last second of course we need to
introduce toxic gases into the mix
because having the endo Raptor the
actual or after the mad scientist's the
evil executive the t-rex all the
henchmen and the still burning house
fire aren't antagonistic enough how can
he smell them enough to turn and check
the spot they were just in but not smell
or hear them enough moving around to the
other side this is supposed to be some
kind of a universal rapture killing
machine here right I don't think this
interrupter even has a sense of smell
and if I were the endo Raptor I'd be
especially frustrated with the way this
diorama has fallen apart in a way that
seems designed to stymie me this is the
most efficient killing machine of all
time but apparently it's only weakness
is hallways that are perfectly straight
god damn it this movie is the poster
child for unnecessary crammed in romance
subplots Christ just about the worst
hiding from killer dinosaur spot I can
imagine can clone kids how did the Endor
Raptor get on the roof you might ask why
did the interrupter get on the roof you
might ask pew says the move this bedroom
sneak seen is the only good thing in the
movie and the scene itself is actually
pretty great but it took so damn long to
get here I just can't get excited about
it
remember Blue's got t-rex blood now so
that'll probably mean something or not
is this the 49th or 50th time the Indo
Raptors had them dead to rights in the
last 10 minutes
I honestly lost count how did Claire get
on the roof you might ask why did Claire
get on the roof you might ask cube again
says the movie what did she have to
point the laser at Owen why not point it
at the roof or the other wing of the
house or a tree in the distance or the
moon there is literally no reason to
further endanger Owens life once you use
the laser point directive feature of the
gun there is foreshadowing and then
there's hey you look at this shadowing
you'd better come take a look at this
cliche good let them die and decrease
the surplus dinosaur population at some
point during the writing of this script
the two writers gave each other a
high-five over their freshly written
cabin in the woods but with dinosaurs
scene actually this may be one of those
rare films that had too few writers I
bet even Lindelof could have improved
things here a bit yeah Claire you press
that button there's no going back he
says this instead of tackling and
citizens arresting her ass he'll kick
her I don't care at this point she is
wrong you must stop her didn't I tell
you that unsupervised children were
literally the worst
there aren't enough timeouts in the
universe to properly punish this child
princess of a jerkwad well honey silver
fish are alive killer bees are alive
John cash is alive but none of those
things add anything to society and only
pose massive risk as invasive species
the next movie's gonna have to be dawn
of the Planet of the dinosaurs given how
many of these got loose at the end of
this one and I for one am NOT interested
in that movie especially if you take
these fools left alive here at the end
and somehow make them central to the
action of the next one I like how they
shipped out these for auction purchase
dinos in a single-file line with no
escorts or helicopters or guards with
extra tranquilizers half the trailers
best moments are literally part of a
montage over ending narration kind of
makes me think you really wanted to make
the movie after this movie but we're
somehow convinced you had to show us the
events of this movie rather than jumping
ahead like the Apes movies or even the
of the Dead movies welcome to Jurassic
world please roll the credits
your skin looks nice it rubs the lotion
on its skin or else it gets the hose
again wiggle your big toe big CGI fight
coming up a mother I was involved deeply
involved in a deception I have deceived
my friends you know and he didn't sold
me every time someone pisses you off do
a doctor go to bed go to sleep
[Music]